-Look at that.
-We have, like, real people.
-Real people.
-In the same place.
-Standing ovation for you.
Yeah, of course.
-Feels like yesteryear.
-Yeah.
Thank you so much for --
for being here, in person.
-No, thank you for having me.
-Well, you have a little
time off before you're just
taking over the world.
September's a big month for you.
-It is a big month, yeah.
-I saw, though --
I follow you on Instagram.
You're a good follow.
-Okay.
-And I saw that you --
-Oh.
-You went golfing.
-Do you love Topgolf?
-I've never been to a Topgolf.
-What?!
-I've never been.
I didn't know
that you were a golfer.
-No. That's different.
[ Laughter ]
That's like saying someone that
likes to putt-putt is a golfer.
No, no, no.
-Oh.
-Which I'm not good
at putt-putt, either.
But -- no, no.
I mean, I can like --
I'm like Happy Gilmore,
like, when I golf.
Like, I can hit it really far.
-Uh-huh.
-But I'm not good at putting.
So -- And I'm really good
at driving the cart.
Like, really good.
With a drink.
[ Laughter ]
But I don't --
No, Topgolf is like a game.
Well, it's a bar.
It's like an atmosphere.
It's a vibe.
It's like a club,
but you're, like,
playing this game.
You're just trying
to nail the balls, like,
into these certain places,
and you play games with people.
And I like playing
'cause I always win.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly, right.
-Yeah, I could hit it
really far, so...
-When you're out, do you ever --
do you ever hear your music,
like, over the loud speakers
or anything?
-Not -- I mean, maybe like a --
like a remix or something.
But, no, I feel like my --
this is a real thing.
I feel like my music is, like,
so family-safe --
Like, you hear me in
dentist offices or like --
[ Laughter ]
Like, I feel like every time
my family or friends go to,
like, a dentist or a doctor,
like, they're always like,
"Oh, I heard your song
again, today."
I'm like, "Sure you did."
Like, it's like -- it's like --
I am this --
I am on the station that is
played in, like, grocery stores
and dentist offices.
-Yeah, you are.
-I'm telling you.
Yeah.
-What do you do if you're in a
grocery store and you come on?
-Well, sing along and dance.
Yes.
I'm a total tool.
[ Laughter ]
-You would do that?
-I literally -- one time in --
I actually --
Actually, I don't even know
if there was music playing
this one time.
It was recently,
'cause I like going to Lowe's.
I'm like --
I love gardening and stuff.
So, I was in Lowe's, and I was
just having a good day,
and I feel like you should
really lean into that right now
in this point in life
if you're having a good day.
And so, I leaned in,
and I just started dancing
and embarrassing my friend
Trisha in Lowe's,
and just started dancing
and singing.
-I did a similar thing
in Target.
-Were you on your knees?
I did a full on --
Got on my knees --
I was very into it.
-Oh, no, I had the --
I was doing, like, a line dance
with my -- with my cart.
-Sure.
-So I was, like,
getting into it.
-Oh, yeah.
-It was -- It was
"Too Hot to Trot,"
by The Commodores.
-Sure.
-♪ Too hot -- ♪
Yeah, that's it.
♪♪
-Yeah, so this jam's on,
it's like...
-Yes.
[ Cheers ]
-And you're just working it.
-♪ Too hot to trot, now, baby ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Too hot to stop ♪
Whoo!
I was into it!
I go --
First of all, I love Target,
by the way.
-I love Target.
-I freaked out!
I go, "What?!"
I had no idea.
-Get it, playlist. Yeah.
-30 stores --
30 stores in the store.
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
there's a produce section,
there's a lawyer.
-You can get bananas
and underwear.
-They have everything
you could --
I've never been
to a store like that.
And then great music playlist?
-Yes.
Well, that's the same thing.
They were playing stuff.
I was dancing in Lowe's, so...
-I love that you do that.
-Yeah.
-Do you know that
"Since You've Been Gone"
is Tony Hawk's hype song?
-No. What?
Is that a joke?
-No. It's for real.
-Oh.
-For real for real.
Tony Hawk, the famous,
legendary skateboarder, to get
hyped up for anything competing,
he'll play
"Since You've Been Gone."
That's his hype song.
-This is my thing.
I feel like I always hear people
talking about how, like,
my music is always on like a --
some Peloton playlist
or some workout like,
"Oh, it's my workout mix."
Like, everyone's --
And I'm like,
"It does not make me
want to work out."
[ Laughter ]
So, um, what?
Why doesn't it
have the same effect?
It's like...
Like, doesn't make me
want to run, but great for you.
-Do you have a song that you
put on if you're working out?
-I have a play--
Well, okay.
Dwayne Johnson has a really good
playlist on Spotify.
Like, if you're looking
for workout playlists.
-See, I think it's intimidating.
I can't do that.
-No, okay.
-I'm never gonna look like
Dwayne -- Dwayne "The Rock,"
or Dwayne Johnson?
[ Laughter ]
-There might be
a Dwayne Johnson out there
that I might look like,
but I'm not gonna
look like The Rock.
-I was on the treadmill for,
like, my heart,
not, like, to lose weight.
I wasn't, like, going for it.
-Yeah, you just want to live.
-Just to try to live my life.
So, no, but I was on it,
and he has --
There's this first one
on one of his playlists,
and it's called "Coming Undone,"
and it's Eric Zayne, maybe.
I had never heard
of this artist, but I love it,
'cause I have to listen
to something that's like,
"I'm a badass."
Like, if I'm on a treadmill,
I'm like, "Yes."
Like, I don't understand
how people listen to, like,
calming stuff.
-On TV, no.
I do television.
-I can't do that, either,
'cause then I just want
to sit down with, like, food.
[ Laughter ]
You're just like, "What?"
Or like a podcast?
I'm like, "This is not making me
want to keep doing this."
-Yeah.
By the way, your show --
By the way, congrats.
-Thank you.
-You won another three Emmys
since I saw you last time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know!
-Congratulations!
-I know.
-You're doing such a great job.
-Thank you.
-It's a great show.
-People love it.
-Who would have thought?
-You're just honest and funny,
and it's positive.
I love it.
-Remember when I was here
a long time ago, though, and
I was like, "What am I doing?"
and then you were, like,
giving me tips.
It was right before it came on,
I was like,
"I don't know
what I'm gonna do."
-Yeah.
Oh, yeah, I said,
"Dude, you got to get, like,
some cooking segments."
-You were like,
"You got to cook."
And I go, "I don't cook."
-"I hate cooking."
-What the hell does that mean?
And I was like --
And "You cook a lot!
You cook a lot on daytime."
-You cook a lot on daytime!
That's just part of the gig.
-I did learn some tips, though,
so there you go.
-And you guys are starting
the season in New York?
-We are.
We have two premiere weeks.
We have --
The first one is in New York,
and we're shooting it right now,
and then we have one in L.A.
So, we're kind of like --
Everybody wants their
lives back, right?
And we're slowly starting
to get there, right?
-Yeah.
-And -- or trying desperately.
And so we came to New York,
and we're celebrating two cities
that people know of them,
but we're kind of representing
all the cities, though.
Like, just trying to get back
to whatever normal
shall be, but...
-Yeah.
-But just like --
'Cause our whole show
is about connection.
This is irony.
And then, right in the middle
of our first season
of connecting, like,
COVID happened and, like,
everyone was isolated.
-Yeah.
And you go, "That's --"
Exactly, yeah.
-Yeah.
So, that was kind of crushing.
So, yeah.
-But I'm happy that you
continued to do your show,
because we all
needed something to watch.
It's like, that's the best time
to step up.
-This is a question for you.
Okay. So, people --
Literally, somebody
just told me this.
They're like, "We're so happy
you kept doing it during the --"
Was that hard for you to, like,
keep going, like,
even if it was from --
'Cause we are humans, too,
and we have our own stuff
in our own backpacks, like,
going through stuff,
and you're having to smile
and make jokes and like --
and that was kind of hard
for a minute.
-It was tough, yeah.
-Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause you don't --
'Cause you're, like,
trying to be like a cheerleader,
to make people feel better.
-It was my wife --
My wife, I'll give her credit.
-Really?
-It was Nancy, yeah.
'Cause I was like --
She was like, "What's the plan?"
I go, "No one knows
what's going on.
We have no plan.
We're just gonna wait it out."
And she goes,
"Oh, no. You go out to Lowe's,
or wherever it is -- Target."
[ Laughter ]
-You build a studio.
-"You build a studio."
-You lazy man.
-Yeah, and she goes,
"And you hold your phone up,
and you do a show.
Broadcast from --
'Cause people need you now."
-Okay. Well, I was in Montana
in like 6 feet of snow.
Like, and everybody was like,
"Let's get into this show."
And I was like, "Sure."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so happy you did, though.
-I'm glad I did,
'cause when you do focus
on helping others,
I think it helps you
through your own stuff.
-I totally agree.
-So, yeah.
-I want to talk to you
about "The Voice."
-I got way off
of track somewhere.
-No, I love it.
Please.
-The whole pre-interview
is screwed.
-Yeah, this is --
Yeah, we don't need any of this.
We didn't stick to any of this.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't know any of it.
-It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
We're having fun.